WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
WE HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US THAT
IS AB SIX OH TWO WITH. MR
BERMAN WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM SO WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BUT PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU FOR A LONG IT WAS AN
EIGHTY SIX OR TWO TODAY. HE HAS
LEGITIMATE INVENTED. SEEKS AS
RELATES OF FILMMAKING. IS IN
USE. I WORK FOR AN AFTERNOON
GAUGING SEXUAL ACTIVITY FOR
SHOWING MORE TO THE WITHOUT
ACTORS CENTER FOR PURCHASES.
SIMILARLY BECAUSE THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS WIDELY AVAILABLE
ONLINE IT IS ALSO BEEN USED
NEFARIOUS LEE AGAINST NON
ACTORS WHOSE PHOTOS HAVE BEEN
SCRAPED FROM THE INTERNET AND
SEAMLESSLY GRAFTED INTO
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL.
BEYOND THE NATURAL FEELINGS OF
EMBARRASSMENT APPEARING IN A
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT DEEP FAKE CAN
CAUSE IRREPARABLE HARM TO A
VICTIM'S REPUTATION JOB
PROSPECTS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS IN MENTAL HEALTH.
SB SIX OH TWO WOULD HELP
RESTORE CONTROL OVER AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IMAGES OR LIKENESS
BY REQUIRING CONSENT TO BE
OBTAINED PRIOR TO DEPICTING A
PERSON AND SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
MATERIAL AND BY ALLOWING THAT
CONSENT TO BE RESCINDED WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS UNLESS
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THIS BILL HAD RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN ON THE
SENATE FLOOR AND IS NO
OPPOSITION AND WITH ME TODAY IS
SAYING WHO'S BEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE SCREEN ACTORS GUILD I
RESPECT ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF
SAG AFTER THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL ALONG WITH THE TEAMSTERS
WHO THEIR ENTERTAINMENT MEMBERS
ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THIS BILL IS PART OF A
NATIONAL CAMPAIGN BY SAG AFTRA
THEY'VE INTRODUCED SIMILAR
BILLS AND OTHER STATES AND AT
THERE DEALING WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO TRY TO. SIMILAR
THINGS IN CONGRESS THE- OUR
MEMBERS. THERE BODIES THEIR
IMAGES THAT IS THEIR LIVELIHOOD
IT. WHEN AND WHEN SOMEONE TO
PICK SIT IN A WAY WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT PARTICULARLY. IN A
MANNER THAT THIS BILL ADDRESSES
WHICH IS SEXUALLY EXPLICIT. IT
CAN REALLY DO A LOT OF DAMAGE.
AND IT NOT ONLY DAMAGES THEM
ECONOMICALLY DAMAGES THEIR ART
BUT ALSO. YOU KNOW DOES A LOT
OF EMOTIONAL DAMAGE AS WELL AND
SO THE POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO
REALLY REMEDY THAT. HOPEFULLY
PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FUTURE NOT ONLY FOR OUR
MEMBERS BUT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THERE ARE LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF THESE VIDEOS. THAT
DEPICT OUR MEMBERS AND. REGULAR
EVERYDAY FOLKS WHO ARE NON
CELEBRITIES WHO ARE BEING
HARASSED BY. SOMEONE THEY KNOW
OR OR SOMEONE THEY DON'T KNOW
AND WE REALLY NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND WE
DRIVER. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
PAUSE FOR A MINUTE AND
ESTABLISH. WE DON'T START THE
OTHER ONE IS IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS IN
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL
IT'S AN IMPORTANT WORKPLACE
PROTECTION SINCE ACTORS AND
ACTRESSES ARE WORKERS AND UNION
MEMBERS PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE HAPPY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS GETTING
AHEAD OF THIS TECHNOLOGY BEFORE
IT'S USED TO HURT MORE PEOPLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION. RIGHT
SIGNALED QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE
DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM THE
SERVER NOT THE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRPERSON FOR THE
LEGISLATION. APPLE OF THINGS
THAT I THINK NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION. YOU ARE DEFINING
DIGITIZATION AND THE BILL AND
YOUR DEFINING IT AS A ONE OF
THREE THINGS NUDE BODY PARTS OF
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING. BEING AS
THE NEW BODY PARTS OF THE
DEPICTED INDIVIDUAL SO THERE
WERE SOME WAS COPIED AND PASTED
A PICTURE OF NUDE BODY PARTS OF
SOMEONE ELSE ON TO THE NEW BODY
PARTS OF SOMEONE IT'S NOT. OF
COMPUTER GENERATED NUDE BODY
PARTS AS A NUDE BODY PARTS OF
THE DEPICTED INDIVIDUAL SO BY
COMPUTER GENERATED YOU HAPPEN
TO FIND THAT BUT I'M ASSUMING
THAT YOU MEAN. LIKE RENDERED IN
A PHOTO REALISTIC MANNER. BY A
COMPUTER. YEAH AND THEN YOU'D
DO SAID DEFECTED INDIVIDUAL
ENGAGING IN SEXUAL CONTACT IN
WHICH THE DEPICTED INDIVIDUAL
DID NOT ENGAGE SO IN OTHER
WORDS YOU'RE TAKING. YOU KNOW
OF. PHOTOGRAPHIC REFERENCE THAT
IT ACTUALLY IS THE DEPICTED
INDIVIDUAL BUT YOU'RE CHANGING
THE ACTION THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
PERFORMING SO. ARE YOU KNOW AS
SOMEONE THAT THAT. IS IN THE
COMPUTER INDUSTRY I THINK
YOU'VE MISSED ONE WHICH IS
THAT. SOMEONE CAN. CAN PAINT
YOU KNOW USING ADOBE PHOTOSHOP
OR SOMETHING. GENITALIA OR
SOMETHING ON TOP OF THE
PHOTOGRAPH OF THE DEPICTED
INDIVIDUAL AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT WOULD CAUSE COUNT IS
BEING COMPUTER GENERATED
BECAUSE WAS ACTUALLY DONE BY A
HUMAN. SO I JUST JUST THOUGHT I
POINT THAT OUT NOW I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE'LL DEFINITELY TAKE
A CLOSER LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
IT'S ALL TOO LATE TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES EITHER BUT I WOULD NOT
ADVISE IT NO IT WOULD CAN COULD
DO TO CLEAN UP LEGISLATION IF
NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE ALL
RIGHT PROUD THAT. AND THEN ONE
QUESTION THAT I DID HAVE
CONCERNS OF THE SECTION OF THE
BILL THAT. CREATE SOME
EXEMPTIONS AND SAYS PERSONS NOT
LIABLE UNDER THE SECTION UNDER
THE FOLLOWING CIRCUMSTANCES IN
ONE OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IS.
BUT IF THE MATERIAL IS A WORK
OF POLITICAL OR NEWS WORTHY
VALUE. SO I'M JUST WONDERING
THAT THE POLITICAL VALUE KIND
OF RAISE MY EYEBROW SO. I MEAN
IF YOUR COMPETITOR IN THE NEXT
ELECTION. RATED ONE OF THESE
DEFECTS I'VE GOT A DIFFERENT
BILL ON THAT BUT AND POSTED IT
AND SAID AND CLAIMED THAT IT
WAS A POLITICAL VALUE TO THEM
WITH THAT EXEMPT THEM FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL. TO
THE CHAIR I THOUGHT WE DON'T
VIEW THAT AS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD EXEMPT THEM FROM THE BILL
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF. OF
THE PRODUCT THAT'S CREATED HERE
WHICH IS SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
MATERIAL. EIGHT HR VIEW THAT
THAT WOULDN'T. ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT YORK YOUR-
WHICH ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES I
THINK THERE ARE THE AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN SAID THERE IT
OTHER LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. ON WHICH WE AGREE A
SIGNIFICANT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL TO COVER
ABOUT SECULAR TYPE OF
EXPRESSION IF THAT IS THE CASE
THEN. WHAT IS MEANT TO BE
EXEMPTED BY. ONE THE BILL SAYS
A WORK OF POLITICAL VALUE. WELL
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY FOR A
FOR A COURT TO DECIDE ARE AT
FOLKS THAT WE WORKED WITH UP
PRIOR TO THE BILL'S
INTRODUCTION WE HAD ENGAGE WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARS ON FREE
SPEECH EXPERTS FOR PROBABLY A
YEAR BEFORE THE SESSION EVEN
BEGAN IN ANTICIPATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE SUGGESTED EXEMPTIONS
THAT THAT THEY SAID WE SHOULD
ANSWERED IN THIS BILL FOR
PROTECTION CONSTITUTIONALLY IF
IT WAS EVER REVIEWED BY A
COURT. SO I THINK OF THAT'S WHY
THAT EXEMPTION IS IN THERE I
CAN. THAT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
BE UP TO A COURT TO DECIDE
EVENTUALLY IF SOMEONE MAKES
THAT CLAIM THAT IT WAS A
POLITICAL EXPRESSION THAT I.
PUT SOMEBODY'S IMAGE THAT WAS
ALTERED ON THE INTERNET. WE'LL
HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE COURT SAID
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OF TRYING TO
REGULATE THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
DOING IT AND A VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED WAY TO AVOID FIRST
AMENDMENT. THEIR CONCERNS AND
VIOLATIONS BUT IT'S A GOOD
POINT AND SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DIG A LITTLE DEEPER INTO ALSO
SURE I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
NOT. TRYING NOT TO EXPOSE
SOMEONE TO LIABILITY UNDER
FIRST AMENDMENT GROUNDS BUT- IT
I HATE TO SEE YOU KNOW
EXEMPTION THAT BROAD PUT IN
THERE BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
IMAGINE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE SOMEONE
COULD SAY ALL THAT THAT HAS
POLITICAL VALUE FOR SURE AND I
BUT THAT THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING QUESTIONS CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. GIVE OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I THINK
THIS RUBBER OUT THE REYES ONE
OF THE- ISSUES THAT'S REALLY AT
THE HEART OF THIS AND A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT. WHILE WE LOOK
AT WHAT WE CAN SEE I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WOULD RECOGNIZE IS
PRETTY OFFENSIVE BEHAVIOR. IN
THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING ALSO
ABOUT CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIPS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER TIME. BY. THINGS
THAT THAT ARE OFFENSIVE BUT
WHEN WE BUMP UP AGAINST FREE
SPEECH RIGHTS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ESPECIALLY THE POLITICAL ROUND
IT GETS TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
THIS COUNTRY HAS LONG AND I
THINK A PROPERLY PROTECTED
POLITICAL SPEECH IS THE HIGHEST
FORM OF SPEECH. THAT'S THERE
AND- FOR AS LONG AS THIS
COUNTRY'S BEEN ENGAGED IN
POLITICS THERE ARE BAD
OFFENSIVE ADVERTISEMENTS
DRAWINGS POLITICAL CARTOONS.
THAT CAST POLITICIANS IN VERY
UNFAVORABLE LIGHTS RIGHT NOW
THOSE TOOLS AS YOU CORRECTLY
POINT OUT ARE. MUCH EASIER AND
MUCH MORE AVAILABLE FOR ANYONE
TO BE ABLE TO GRAB. GRAB
SCREENSHOTS RENDER THEM
DIFFERENTLY BE ABLE TO MOVE AND
DRAW IN PRETTY REALISTIC
REPRESENTATIONS OF THINGS BODY
PARTS THAT THAT AREN'T THERE
AND IN FACT ACTIONS AND
ACTIVITIES. GIVEN THE POWERS OF
THE COMPUTERS THAT DIDN'T
REALLY HAPPEN SO WE'RE TREADING
ON PRETTY NEW GROUND HERE AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL. IN TRYING TO CONSTRUCT
PROTECT PEOPLE ABSOLUTELY BUT
HOW WE CONSTRUCT THOSE
PROTECTIONS THESE ARE THE ARE
THE TRADITIONAL RIGHTS THAT THE
CONSTITUTION WANTS TO AND NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT. IT ARE
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AND
THAT'S WHY IF YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS. WE TRY AND GO INTO
SOME OF THIS AND SOME OF THE
DELICACIES THAT ARE IN HERE AND
SOME OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION MAY GET TESTED
IN COURT MAY NOT GET TESTED IN
COURT BUT OVER TIME. AT THE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL HOW WE DO THIS AND
THINK MORE BROADLY ABOUT HOW WE
MAKE SURE WE'RE PROTECTING WHAT
WE NEED TO PROTECT. OUT
UNDERMINING LONGSTANDING
TRADITIONAL. FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT SO YOU'RE YEAH YOU'RE
YOUR QUESTIONS ARE WELL TAKEN
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THAT HERE BUT THIS IS I THINK
OF AN APPROPRIATE BILL AT THIS
TIME AND WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS
GOES BUT I KNOW WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE'S CAN BE WRESTLING
WITH EXACTLY THIS ISSUE IN ITS
MYRIAD FORMS. OVER TIME AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A
COURT WITH ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND THEN MISTER BERMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE STONE. HERE GALLAGHER.
CHAO TO GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
NORRIS REYES. HI MR MAJOR WILL
TAKE YOUR MOTION. SECOND BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE THANK YOU SIR
BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECT
FAST RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THE. WE THE MOTION IS THAT
WE CAN COVER IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT WILL SEND
THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I CHAU
CHIU. GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I RACE RACE I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES WE
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WHICH I WELL I'M
TOLD ARE ON THEIR WAY. GONZALEZ.
ALL RIGHTS THIS IS TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE. CHAO CHU
CHU AYE GONZALEZ HOLDEN KILEY.
COPY OF THE MEMBERS. CHAO
GONZALEZ HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KILEY
. WE HAVE TO MEMBERS THIS
IS AB SIX OH TWO BY BERMAN
CHOW. CHOW I GONZALEZ KILEY.
THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT I AM TOLD
THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE UNLIKELY
TO BE HERE THEY ARE CAUGHT UP
WITH OTHER THINGS AT THIS POINT
SO. THE BILL IS OUT AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED